le sport maintenant et la formule 1
automobile pour commencer grand prix de
france une nouvelle victoire pour le
champion du monde en titre le français
alain prost sur mclaren honda derrière
lui je dirais que c'est presque devenu
un classique son compagnon d'écurie
ayrton senna suivi d' alboreto sur
ferrari
lionel chamoulaud le trion d'alain prost
32e victoire en grand prix la quatrième
cette saison cela faisait cinq ans qu'il
n'avait pas gagné le grand prix de
france
certainement qu'à son goût on parle trop
d'ayrton senna aujourd'hui il lui a
donné la leçon
pourtant alors que le france et part en
tête senna prend le commandement après
les changements de pneumatiques prost
attaque alors le brésilien qui évite
sous pression la boîte de vitesses de
senna connaît des problèmes
prost qui est à l'affût et elle alors
toute sa science de la course pour le
passé à l'endroit le plus rapide du
circuit
une attaque à l'intérieur alors que
senna est bloqué par la minardi de perez
à la que votre manoeuvre pour reprendre
la première place est une manoeuvre des
baux et j'y ai pensé dans la voiture
j'ai pensé dans un moteur parce que je
pense que c'est exactement une et madame
mais je veux qu'ils auraient fait
lui-même
bon c'est l'opportunité bien entendu on
peut c'est pas des manoeuvres que l'on
peut prévoir mais
je pense que je l'aurais je voulais
quand même
relativement facilement avant l'open
source
extraordinaire lucidité prost c'est un
super sénat capitule
il est à la limite de la consommation le
français est en route pour une nouvelle
victoire et l'emportent devant senna
donc alboreto burger piqué et nannini au
classement du championnat du monde prost
possède 15 points d'avancé sur ayrton
senna prochain grand prix dimanche à
silverstone
alors